in 2019 Toyota was named the most
valuable car company in the world one
year later they lost that title to Tesla
if this doesn't sound like much consider
this the first time Toyota got that
title was in 2008 71 years after the
company was founded Tesla on the other
hand was founded in 2003 so do the math
but all things come to an end and while
Tesla might have beaten its gas-powered
counterparts there are new EVS
threatening to take the title what are
these new EVS that will overtake Tesla
let's find out the Tesla company
currently offers seven distinct electric
vehicles out of those seven we will be
covering the four that are currently in
production the model 3 will be the first
and it is currently Tesla's most
affordable offering positioned as
Tesla's Mass Market vehicle we will be
pitching it against another Mass Market
TV the Chevy bolt next we have the model
y Tesla's response to the incredibly
lucrative SUV Market we will pit the
model y against the 2022 Hyundai ioni 5.
how will these two measure up against
one another you will find out in a bit
after the why we move on to the eggs
another luxury crossover SUV that Sports
the enviable wingtip doors we will pit
the X against the Kia ev9 a vehicle that
comes with its own unique method of
opening doors our last stop will be with
the luxurious Model S a luxury sedan
that many have called a supercar in
Disguise we will pitch this devastating
beauty against another luxurious
Supercar called the Lucid air Sapphire
good good now let the games begin this
is ridiculous I know and trust me there
are some other ridiculous picks ahead
but I can prove why they all make sense
on paper and in real life there's no
comparing the Chevy bolt to the model 3.
the model 3 wins on almost every front
the 2023 Chevy ball TV's best version
has an estimated 0 to 60 miles an hour
acceleration time of 6.8 seconds while
the 2022 Tesla Model 3 base version the
standard range does it in 5.8 seconds
now when you bring it in Elite version
into the group chat the model 3 flaws
the bolts with an acceleration time of
only 3.1 seconds then there is the
interior design where Tesla clearly
appears to take the crown once again its
minimalist interior oozes Innovation and
it Sports an impressive 15-inch
touchscreen display that controls most
of the car's functions including the
heating of its roomy cabin with
comfortable seats the 2023 Chevy balti
UV doesn't fall short either it also
offers a similar spacious cabin
comfortable seats and a 10.2 inch
touchscreen display with Alexa built in
a feature that would be invaluable to
the millions of Alexa users but at the
end of the day the difference is clear
and the model 3 is an undeniable winner
so why am I comparing these two price
and affordability Elon Musk wanted the
model 3 to be Tesla's most affordable
offering made for the mass Market but
how many people can afford a 42 000 car
now compare that with the Chevy bolt
that retails at just 27 000 then
consider the fact that those who would
go for the model 3 just want an
affordable EV and if they don't mind
ditching the Tesla brand they'd still
get quality from the Chevy but at a
lesser price and if you didn't know
Chevy has a policy of installing a
charging Outlet in your home for free if
you buy one of their cars Tesla won't
offer that without draining your wallet
so you can see how the Chevy might
eventually Devour the model 3's market
share moving on from Electric sedans
Tesla created the model X to be their
all-electric luxury SUV and as with most
luxury SUVs on the market they are meant
to be high performance and yet somewhat
worth the Hefty Buck you will have to
spend on it but that is where the
problem lies at 109 000 as its starting
price the model X just cost too much
especially when with a few extra
thousands you can buy an s-plat this is
why I am convinced that the upcoming Kia
ev9 will consume the model X's market
share comparing base models the model X
Falls ridiculously short the model X is
inferior to the Kia ev9 which will have
a horsepower of 300 and 20 against the
model X's 259 when it comes to range the
Kia Falls a little short at 300 miles to
the model X's 348 but all of that Fades
when you consider the shocking reality
that this shoulder to shoulder drag race
of specs comes from a Kia that costs 56
990 for its base model in fact its most
expensive GT version will only cost as
much as seventy thousand dollars now is
all that extra performance worth the
extra tens of thousands of dollars for
the SUV you'll be the judge but let's
talk about the interior for a moment
because this is where the Kia shines
like a space Rock I know I praised the
Tesla earlier when comparing it to the
Chevy bolt but that was with the Chevy
this is Ikea and the design of the
latter looks Exquisite enough to make
Tesla's minimalist design boring and
repetitive the Kia will sport a 12.3
inch touchscreen display with a spacious
cabin comfortable seats and door opens
that open sideways it's Kia announcing
how different they intend to be and for
me it works especially at that price
price when Tesla made the model why they
had the model X in mind how can we make
a more Compact and affordable version of
an already supposedly affordable model X
they must have thought when Hyundai made
the ioniq 5 I am certain they had the
model Y in mind how can we mess up the
model Wise Market share they must have
thought and they came close too close
for comfort the Hyundai ioniq 5 is one
of the most serious contenders in the EV
game right now the ioniq 5 prioritizes
safety and comfort it has a spacious and
modern interior with the minimalist
design and high quality materials it
also features a 12.3 inch infotainment
touchscreen the seats are comfortable
and supportive and there's plenty of
Headroom and leg room in the cabin for
passengers the model y also offers all
these features including a larger
15-inch touchscreen but it makes the
same error that most of its other
offerings make it maxes out on
performance the ioniq 5 comes in two
battery sizes a 58 kilowatt hour battery
with 215 horsepower and a 72.6 kilowatt
hour battery with 302 horsepower it can
go from 0 to 60 miles an hour in around
6 seconds and has a range of up to 300
miles this is beyond impressive for
anyone looking for a solid affordable
SUV the Tesla Model y on the other hand
comes in two battery sizes a long-range
version with 326 horsepower and a
performance version with 456 horsepower
it can go from zero to 60 miles an hour
in around 3.5 seconds for its
performance version and has a range of
up to 326 miles for its long range
version to the Casual Observer this
seems like a deal breaker right right
wrong in truth it is overkill and that's
probably why they can't match the ionic
in terms of affordability because when
you get an ionic that costs around ten
thousand dollars less than the Y you
haven't offered that's a little too
difficult to turn down but at the end of
the day it all depends on you and how
much you are willing to spend and save
at a base price of 249 000 the Lucid air
Sapphire is the only Contender on this
list to be more expensive than the Tesla
we're comparing it to and the Tesla in
question is the 114
990 Model S plaid so does the Lucid air
justify its price tag hell yes right out
of the gate the Lucid air Sapphire
delivers 1 200 horsepower nearly 200
horsepower more than the Tesla Model S
plaid additionally it has a range of up
to 520 miles on a single charge making
it one of the longest range electric
vehicles on the market the Tesla Model S
plan on the other hand has a range of
just 396 miles on a single charge which
is still impressive but is at least 100
less than the Lucid Air at the moment
almost everyone agrees that the Lucid
air is faster than the Tesla Model S
plaid but the domination doesn't end
there in its interior the Lucid offers
more space for its occupants than the
Tesla S plaid it also offers more
luggage space under an automotive
package it calls Lucid space concept
which maximizes available space for the
comfort of passengers and Luggage now if
you're talking about the external build
the Lucid air also comes out on top with
its glass canopy roof that is one with
its windshield and offers a panoramic
view of the sky that allows just enough
natural light into the car without
exposing passengers to excessive heat
and harmful Rays eventually the final
blow comes from its software performance
and integration already we know that the
software of the Tesla Model S is
incredibly formidable and one of the
reasons why it's still considered the
best of the best but the Lucid air
Sapphire might be taking the bar a
little higher with their 32 sensors that
greatly advances the driver assist
capabilities the model S on the other
hand has 12 ultrasonic sensors all in
all both the Lucid air Sapphire and the
Tesla Model S plaid are impressive
electric vehicles with their own
strengths and weaknesses but the Lucid
air is a faster vehicle has a longer
range and a more luxurious interior with
a larger and more advanced display and
when you consider that people who can
afford the model S can easily afford the
Lucid air Sapphire who do you think is
going to come out on top